to steal from the empire
you just walk in like you belong
[Music]
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they can't
imagine that someone like me
[Music]
would ever get inside their house
tell me about the moment
that you found out that cassian's story
was gonna go beyond rogue one like was
it a phone call where were you i don't
know because it took time first i i
received the phone call
saying would you be happy to explore the
possibility of doing something uh you
know in this new long format we're
exploring for disney plus about
cassian's background and i was like yeah
that sounds great i mean to be honest i
never thought it was gonna happen you
know i was like ah yeah this is one of
those calls that you get and we'll see
if something like they were very
cautious on the words used you know and
and and i'm glad it was like that
because it took us time to find out
exactly uh what we wanted to do you know
this idea of visiting the the five years
prior uh rogue one
it's quite quite interesting you know
because it's it's close enough so i can
do it
and
you know it's not a kid it's not like a
teenager it's like i can do it but at
the same time is enough time to have a
transformation you know to to create a a
a
an emotional uh
arc that can can
walk us through the awakening of our
revolutionary you know uh it's enough
time to start with a character that
doesn't know he's capable of what he
does in rogue one uh and that's that's
uh
that's something that came out later you
know when tony tony pitched me his idea
uh
and i thought he was perfect i thought
it was strong and and interesting and
bold and risky
and that's when i started celebrating
you know when i realized holy we are
doing something there is something here
and uh and that was like four years ago
uh so it's been quite a long time you
know yeah i love how you said um
it was five years before rogue one so in
your head you were like i can do this
because i heard that you were actually
concerned
that you were going to look older
well i mean not not just concern i mean
i am older
i i am older there's no no way to stop
that but
did you like address or talk about that
at all like how did you prepare you know
for your comeback to star wars i mean
not much because it's a convention right
i mean like that's that's what we do
it's like
it's it's uh it's what it is and
it's more in the work you can do uh uh
in terms of the behavior of the
character that you can you can feel that
childish kind of like approach you know
to to his everyday life to his decisions
i've been
you know thinking a lot about like okay
if the guy is so sure of
of
what he needs to do and he's trained
when we meet him in rogue one and he's a
man on a mission uh how how can we show
uh
someone
way more immature how would he relate to
others and and to fear or to risk or and
and that's when
when your work can be about that you
know and can help on that also he's on
the writing you know like the the the
writing of of tony portrays a a very
young and kind of confused cassian you
know uh when we meet him he doesn't know
what he wants he's in a very cynical
moment of his life uh he's just
surviving and living every day uh in a
very selfish
mode you know uh
and and then
hopefully the the change will start to
happen and he'll start growing and and
getting to
that place where he ends up
i mean willing to sacrifice everything
for a cause you know right right it's so
interesting like how you were how you're
able to step in and explore how you were
saying how he relates to fear and sort
of his maturity level like i think
that's so cool and tony's writing is so
brilliant i want to ask you about that
but because this show spans five years
obviously leading up to rogue one season
one is the first year season two is um
the next four do you know how how this
story ends and like how much are you
given before
you sign on
if i know how this story ends you mean
the first the first season like season
two
oh yes i know
i know where it ends
it ends the day rogue one starts you
know like definitely and and that is
like like we it's it's interesting
because you never approach storytelling
like this you know
we know what the end is but you know
what the end is uh everyone knows what
the end is so
i mean the beauty and the
the
many chances or possibilities that we
find the freedom we have is in how we
get there know where we get you know
it's like when you do a historical piece
you know
everyone knows an event you know but you
i love those films you know when
that are about a real character or an
event that happened in history and you
go see you watch a movie about
everything you don't know you know all
the intimate
journey the the choices made for
something that you know happen to happen
you know something that you know happens
uh and and it's interesting because it
kind of like re-signifies the event you
know i think you're gonna go back to
rogue one and you're gonna see it
differently after experiencing andor
because you'll get to know what he means
when he says i've been in this fight
since i was six years old now you will
know what he's talking about you know he
talks about a dark past he says in rogue
one i've done terrible things for the
rebellion well we'll get to know what
that is you know and and that's the
story we're telling you
yes and the story that you and tony are
telling together i mean when i was
watching at diego i was like this is
very it feels very dark than what we're
used to seeing in star wars like the
tone feels very adult like he was like
drinking out of a flask i was like whoa
this is so cool you know what
conversations were you and tony having
as far as tone goes because it's so
different
well we were
asked to be different you know
tony gilroy wouldn't be here if we were
not supposed to be different you know uh
the the idea of this show is that it
definitely is
is darker is greedier
it's more of a spyish thriller you know
with
that kind of mystery and and darkness
that that brings we can be political you
know it is about uh politics you know
there is a lot happening in the galaxy
and uh and we can tackle that uh yes we
have to be ambitious in terms of
the adventure and the action
you know and the big scope in in like uh
the the big scope in science fiction
that star wars represents but uh we can
also be the other you know we can also
explore other tones that is what the
long format brings you know we have the
time for four films
in these 12 episodes basically
so we can
move from one to the other
and the idea was to make sure that once
you think you know what the series is
about once you think you know which
characters you're going to be around
what's the tone going to be like we
change we transform we go somewhere else
you know
and and the series will keep having
those jumps
so
so we we we hope people are entertained
till the end because they they don't
know what's to come you know
yeah no totally i it's going to be like
such a wild ride do you do you and pedro
pass galadol
have like a friendly star wars rivalry
now that you're in this tv format do you
guys talk about your characters
i couldn't have a rivalry with that man
he's just pure love you know
pedro is like every time i i've seen him
a few times in my life and he's been the
kindest
in every every time you know and so
sweet and and feels like yeah he feels
like a brother
you know already and and i know him very
little uh i don't think so at all
it'll be the opposite i'm sure we're
gonna go out and get drunk and talk
about the experience and how crazy it is
sometimes
people
are standing up
first of all congratulations
um i know that you've actually
auditioned for other star wars roles
before how do you know that
and now you have one so i was wondering
if you would you know talk to me about
maybe those other show like what what
have you auditioned for in the past and
maybe talk more about that
oh i don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna
spill the beans like that um
i have auditioned for other star wars
i'm a big star wars fan and i've always
sort of tried to find my role or my
place within the
galaxy or in the universe um just
because i'm such a big fan um
and i really think that i'm sort of
happy i'm really happy actually that i
didn't get those roles and then i got
bix instead i think
she's so powerful um
and so fearless and yet so caring and
she's quite complex and her dynamic with
cassian is so interesting and so fun to
play that i'm i'm excited i ended up
getting
this i will tell you that
the one that i didn't get i was very
upset about and i ended up skydiving and
i remember being like leave it on the
plane and then i just jumped off and i
never kind of thought about it again
wow
of that isn't it so funny like we hold
on that we attach ourselves to outcomes
so much but then it ends up it ends up
working out so perfectly
i think it's a good lesson that things
don't happen
at you but happen for you 100 percent i
am i'm such a strong believer in that
and that's why it makes it even more
exciting for me to watch you in this
role i know that you uh you also wanted
to get a bix tattoo but you were nervous
that maybe people or
would see it before the show came out
and it would give it away
so now
so now with the show coming out
are you thinking of getting that tattoo
i think i'm gonna do it i yeah i think
i'm i'm i'm gonna do it um i don't know
exactly what i originally wanted to get
just bix because i just think it's such
a cool
name
um and i remember telling that to tony
and he's like you can't do that no one
knows your name yet what are you doing
and i was like oh shoot yeah
um
like
i don't know
i don't know what i'll
get maybe like
coordinates or something
or something to do with
that world yeah i love it um well let's
talk about that world more because you
definitely explained
more about bix and how you know she's
fearless she's just so much badassery to
her
and i really love her dynamic with uh
andor and so i wanted to talk about or i
wanted to ask you about rather
the backstory that you built with diego
because it feels like there's a lot of
tension between cassian and bix
i wanted to like ask you more about that
like what's the t tell me the t yeah
let's let's spill it like what's going
on
um
i think they're childhood friends i mean
we had so many discussions tony me and
diego and um
and i think without going too much into
detox i don't know how much i can talk
about that but there are childhood
friends and and you can almost feel
the tension comes from like trust being
broken and rebuilt and broken and
rebuilt over the course of many many
many many years and i think vixx is at a
level of
sort of maturity and stability where she
runs her own show and she has this great
career she has which she's always dreamt
of having which is this sal yard all for
herself and
she's the boss and
she wants to protect it and that
stability to her feels safe and at home
and and that's kind of why she
has
him in her life um and then cassie
always just comes around and
goes i need you to lie for me i need you
to do this or can i i don't know what to
do or help and i think she has this deep
love for cassie and that she sort of can
help but protect him and love him um
because there is so much so much history
there oh i love it well i can't wait to
find out more about you know those two
characters and and how they're involved
with each other and and yeah all that
rich history that's very exciting um you
did mention that you're a huge star wars
fan and so because
my so my and my favorite star wars
moment of all time is actually in rogue
one
when vader comes out and so i wanted to
ask you what is your favorite star wars
moment or maybe one that you like really
i think i do think that ending of rogue
one is probably
cinematically is
so incredibly impactful yeah and really
is the reason i i pinched myself when i
got this role because i could not
believe that i was going to work with
the guy that wrote that and and created
that it was
i think that has to be my favorite
moment i know i almost want to say
another moment because i don't want it
to be about roman um but it truly is
just so impactful
i love that well obviously you brought
up um tony who is just so brilliant and
the writing and i've been talking to
everyone today about the tone of the
show and how
it just feels so dark and so different
than what we're used to seeing like i
there's a scene that vixx is in
and it just felt very adult to me i was
like whoa i've never seen that in star
wars before like it feels like we're
seeing things that feel very adult that
i've never seen in star wars before and
so i was wondering if you and tony uh
you know were there any talks or
conversations that you were having about
tone or what notes were you given as far
as tone goes because the tone of the
show is so cool
yeah i think tone was very much set by
tony and the conversations and even
rehearsals that we sort of
had that he was a part of and also our
directors were incredible at creating
that and i think
every director sort of brings their own
little spark to each
episode that they direct
um and they all direct so differently
but yet tony sort of remained the middle
and the sort of like the
firm leader that sort of led us through
the entire show
um so i think tone
really has to go to the writing and has
to go to tony um
even i i remember even conversations
being had in in
in what's it called in rehearsal where
you almost want to
go to the comedy side of things or you
almost want to make things lighter
because you are in this world that
you're so
used to and we watch it so much and
reeling us back to the reality of what
we're talking about the reality of the
world that we're living in and
truly sort of trying to remove the fact
that we're in a galaxy far far away and
really honing down on the story itself
that just happens to be in a galaxy far
far away
it's fermenting out there song
you're in my net
are you a fish
are you a thief
congratulations star wars i'm such a
major fan so when people new people come
into star wars like i have to ask you
kyle and denise like what was
the pinch me moment for you on set was
it seeing yourself in uniform for the
first time like what was tell me about
that moment when you were like oh my god
i'm in star wars
oh it's funny because you see i i sort
of wish i could be like that i was
geeking out all the time but i i wasn't
a star wars aficionado i had never seen
it i
what was my pinch me was when i was in
talks about this role and i thought i
don't know if this is for me i don't
think it's my jam i don't think it's and
then i read the scripts and i was like
hang on
you're telling me that these scripts
this writing
is going to be in space like this is
going to be in star wars and
and then it changed the whole game for
me because i i had kind of written
myself out of this kind of thing because
science fiction isn't my thing and also
theater is my thing and it takes a lot
to draw me away
from the theater onto screen because the
parts are better for women on stage
and so i mean the money but but but my i
get my thrills from playing great women
on stage and then
i get sent these scripts and he tells me
about this great really dark woman that
i could play
in star wars so i was like oh my god i'm
going to get to do both things like
really great work really great character
building work
but it's going to be in star wars but it
really is only like the last two days
that i'm having pinch me's and when i
saw the trailer and i was on a poster
and my nephews were going nuts and i was
like oh my god i'm star wars
so now and when people like you who are
really into it and you say welcome to
the star wars world and i think oh my
god i am genuinely being welcomed into
this thing that you guys have been
fueling for so long like it's amazing
and one more thing we were interviewed
by a
and he has his ten-year-old
podcast and but we were i
we were quite emotional because this is
the only show you could do where a 10
year old and a 75 year old could get
together in a room and be as excited as
each other
about star wars like there's nothing
else that does that there's nothing that
connects those two generations in the
way that something like star wars does
so it's a total privilege now for me to
feel
oh my god it's amazing yeah yeah a
little overwhelming but that was so
beautiful to hear though that it's like
you're living through the pinch me right
now kyle what about you
yeah i agree the pinch me is happening
currently as we speak yeah these last
this last week has been nuts um
but yeah
like
when we had started filming it was it
was
in the middle of the pandemic and and so
a lot of the context of what we were
doing was changed and shifted and
and so
it's on set and and kind of been
overtaken and swept away by tony's
drama that he had written you know it's
a socio-political commentary while also
being
a thriller in space and also a family
drama a kitchen sink drama it goes you
know it's vast and it's intimate and i
was just kind of like wow this is just
like a really good project and then
um
we're on this unbelievable set that had
been built that was like eight acres
long and wide it was a whole town and
there was this group milling about
before we had started filming and i was
walking through and they parted
and there was a line of storm troopers
that was about 30 deep and i just was
large froze yeah and just lost my mind i
was like
oh oh my god no i'm in star oh my god
i'm in star wars seeing storm troopers
is sort of undeniable you're sort of
like yeah okay that's hap hang on yeah
and the other thing was like
i have
it's wonderful because cyril
has a has a journey where he kind of
loses a lot he has to go back home
and he spends a lot of time with his
mother at one point so bizarre and she's
like feeding him breakfast and the
cereal is like
space cereal and the milk is blue and i
was like
oh well no of course it is you forget
that it's in space like i visited that
set so i remember going oh i really want
to see inside cyril's apartment and i
went in and i was like
are you kidding me like it's like
everything is like an apartment in real
life
but it's not because it's in space and
those cereals blew my mind yeah
it's wild i would love to drink out of
blue milk any day yes
and uh or have blue milk in my cereal
rather how do your characters uh relate
to cassian
and
how i feel like what's driving them
because they're so loyal to the empire
and i was curious as to like what's
driving
them and what their goals are
well dedra is super ambitious like she's
so proud to work for the empire but
she's i mean she's surrounded by
men that aren't doing a very good job
and it must i think that what i love
about it is this kind of initial
introduction to dedra is like woman in a
man's world and go on sister we believe
in you and then you realize oh but she's
the fascist
do i still believe in her do i want her
to succeed it's like
i i feel like for for dedra in order to
succeed in a regime like this fascist
regime you have to prove yourself by
doing things that get you
the acclaim and for her
catching cassie and andor because nobody
believes her when she's saying
this is a problem and everyone's saying
oh no stop it stop it these privileged
men are all telling her silly woman
which she knows and that her her
kind of objective becomes i am going to
bring him in
and when i bring him in i am going to be
up there
like she wants to take over
the empire yeah and she needs you know
friends
[Laughter]
that was such an evil laugh it was so
good
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah cyril i mean
yeah we were talking earlier about how
we're kind of adolescent villains yeah
um we're we're not fully formed yet yeah
um which is the exciting thing about
about playing these characters and
and for cyril he's
he's got he's i mean he breathes
ambition he's desperate to transcend his
station he's desperate to get
to the top of the ranks of the corporate
security sector and he's actually really
desperate to get into the isb
yeah and um he's drunk the empire
kool-aid but actually his
you know his
his morals are actually quite
understandable you know we've all been
in a situation where we think everybody
is like not doing a good enough job
and
somebody's been murdered like shouldn't
we investigate that like aren't like you
could see how he's doing the right thing
but in the wrong climate yeah i guess
cassian exists as a foil for him and
and
i think as much rigidity and um
constraint that exists within cyril
um
the the freedom and the kind of
messiness that that
um cassian represents
is just so infuriating and he senses
like dedra does that that there is a
potential for that to
turn into something greater and
something that needs to be stopped so
he's just like a dog with a bone with
cassian and then
once he finds deadred and that's
yeah ooh
that is a
it's like a meat cute that's what
somebody said earlier a journalist said
tell us about the meat a little
villainous meat
oh my god that's so good which would
probably love it the star wars people
where
you were saying that it's like at the
taylors because you know cyril is really
obsessively tailoring his uniform and
then when i went to my first fitting i
said to the designer i was like oh i
really think we need to tailor this and
like make and he said i can't believe
you as dedra and denise have said you
need to tailor this uniform because
cyril and kyle
both needed that's like a really major
thing and i was like oh we're gonna get
on so well we're gonna live in a perfect
little house full of really tailored and
clean
yeah it's gonna control everything
controlled environment yeah
as long as everyone thinks i'm an
irritation
that's a good chance they'll miss what
i'm really doing what are you really
doing
genevieve i'm so
excited for you
when you were cast as
mon mothma in revenge of the sith did
you ever think that you were going to be
like playing her this many times
i mean never i mean no
i it's such
an extraordinary and unique opportunity
to get to revisit this character
a number of times in my career and to
get to play her at different times in
her life
and now in this moment in andor to
really be able to get
to develop her and to discover her in a
way that we've never seen her before
how does mon mothma's
story relate to cassians because i feel
like that's something a lot of people
are going to be wondering like while
watching this series
i think that's really understandable and
that's an exciting part of this series
because we know that it is the prequel
to rogue one so we know
that
mon mothma introduces kat
or in rogue one to gin
she introduces him as cassian andor from
rebel intelligence so she introduces him
as a spy
and
she sets them off on this mission that
is
so important
to the um the star wars lore
and yet ultimately fatal for them
and i've always wondered
what it was
for her to ask that question of cassian
to send them on that mission
knowing that
they could probably die
in
doing that i i've i've always wondered
what she'd been through as a woman what
the sacrifices she had had to make
before she was in that position of
leadership and to be able to ask that of
people and so they are connected and we
know that we have to get to that point
we start
and or
where they're not even on the same
planet
um
they're they are so
and they're certainly not connected in
in any way with any
[Music]
rebel network in fact what's interesting
about andor is
that there doesn't seem to be a unified
rebel network at all this is almost
this is the beginning of the rebellion
this is there are only whispers of
rebellion and so each of them has to
effect change in their own way
and so
mon feels quite isolated at the
beginning of andor
her
she's working within the senate
within empire
to try and change but i feel like she's
been doing it for so long
she's so tired of the opposition she's
so tired of hitting that wall of power
that is palpatine and his allies
she's been so ineffective
that she has to
reach to a world
that is
murkier that is less clear
and i think that is something that is
interesting about where we start and or
is that it is less
the goodies and the baddies it is less
black and white it is less empire and
rebellion
and there are layers
within
in it it is murkier it is grayer
they each have
have good
they have good intentions or perhaps
good intentions
but
they have to
enter
and make maybe questionable decisions
yeah it's as a sour sand it's super
gnarly to hear you talk about mon mothma
in this way and sort of walk us through
what her pov is and how she's feeling
because i know you're so connected to
the character i wanted to know genevieve
how do you because
for a lot of people when they saw him on
mothma it was in return of the jedi so
how do you connect the dots from andor
to return of the jedi as far as mon
mothma's story goes
yeah that's what's so exciting and it's
really interesting to have the
opportunity to almost go backwards to
fill in in in a way that you never get
to right so
you know when i was first um
allowed to step into her shoes or given
the the the chance to step into her
shoes i was a very young actor
and um was one of my first jobs and i
remember studying that scene in return
of the jedi like
over and over and over again trying to
un to to really trying to work at her
voice and her syntax
trying to feel maybe where she was from
you know i was such so great and then
each time i have gone back to play her i
do go back and watch that scene because
it's caroline who originated her
caroline blackstone with george lucas
created a woman
in the early 1980s
who was a female leader of a rebel
alliance
that's extraordinary and she's a woman
i continue to want to stand up for
so
when i go back and watch that scene each
time it kind of grounds me in who she is
and so i hope to
when we and this is the great hope that
when we finish the two seasons of andor
that it will walk us into rogue one
and that everything that we discover
about this woman
within andor
will
will kind of
fill in or influence how we watch those
performances
going forward in the storytelling arc
i'm hopeful that we can do that because
i'm
i was always curious about her
so my curiosities from her from that
very first time still feed into the work
i tried to do with her now uh it's all
so exciting i remember when i love that
you brought up caroline blakiston
because
when you were actually casted in rogue
one she was very elated and actually
said i would love to get tea with her
one day um that would be a hoot and i
was wondering did you ever get tea with
caroline or would you like to exchange
notes with her if not
do you know just as the pandemic was
starting
her and i went
and i had never met her before and
we were without knowing we were at the
same meeting in a hotel in central
london
and
she said to me
you're genevieve o'reilly and i said i
am and she said i'm carolyn blakeston
and i was like
oh my gosh and it was this wonderful
moment and the two of us just
hugged each other
and i was saying i think you're just
extraordinary and we were each other's
biggest fans and it was a beautiful
beautiful moment
um
yeah she's
i have such great respect for her and
her work not just in star wars but the
other work that she has done as an actor
and i feel very fortunate and very
grateful that i can step into her shoes